professor at University Antwerp and
Belgium he's held positions at
University of Edinboro and University of
Helsinki he's a research interests are
in database Theory data quality and more
recently today's topic of graph learning
and he's been recognized for his work in
Data Mining and data quality and
particularly we received ACM pods
Alberto Omen Mendelson test of time
award for his work on XML and was
recipient of the prestigious iclr
outstanding paper for his work on graph
neural networks and today he's going to
tell us about the power of graph
learning so please join me in welcoming
florists
foreign
thank you for the nice and very generous
introduction also thanks for the
invitation both from people here at
Simon's but also the the uh you know the
the bosses of the our program so today I
will talking about talking about a graph
learning and actually the this talk is
part of a program which is called logic
and algorithms in database Theory and Ai
and so I looked at some of the topics
logic and so I'm actually not really
like a very good expert in like logic
create languages I know queer languages
but I'm not really a very expert in
query languages AI I don't know much
about AI I know a little bit about
machine learning circuits which is also
a topic in the program I'm not an expert
in that at all but fortunately in the
intersection there is graph learning and
so the last couple of years I've been
actually working in the graph learning
area and that's why you know this is
going to be a perfect fits for this part
yeah okay
so so what is graph learning so this is
supposed to be like a general audience
CS kind of style of presentation so I
will be very high level throughout the
entire talk okay
so graph learning basically in a
nutshell it's like about prediction and
classification of problems related to
graphs and this kind of classification
prediction prediction problems they come
in various uh forms and shapes you can
have on the vertex level you can have a
subgraph level on the HR HR link level
but also on the graph level okay so
there are different types of prediction
and classification problems that you can
think of across okay cool sorry
okay
[Music]
there we go
okay so what are more concrete examples
yeah so we have for example vertic
classification there you want to
categorize like online users and items
for example or find amino acid locations
in lot protein structures and this is
like a very known like Alpha folds is a
very successful protein folding
prediction I think and on under the
hoods you find some graph learning
aspects there link prediction very
important you have knowledge curves and
these are incomplete you want to kind of
complete them using links connections
between people between entities and so
you want to predict you know what are
what is new information hidden in the
craft that we can basically kind of find
out okay
and then of course we also like
recommender systems these are typically
bipartite curves you have users and
items and you want to predict
connections and they're basically just
going to tell these users might be
interested in a particular item to buy
and so on an Android drug side effect
Discovery is another example of Link
prediction where for example a protein
protein network with drugs and so on and
you want to predict edges between drugs
and these will basically indicate
whether or not there might be a side
effect
classification example of that could be
just simply like a prediction of a
molecular property of a graph okay okay
and then finally subcrafters can be a
traffic prediction something which we
use very often is like how do you get
from here to Jupiter uh you know close
by to have a nice drink in the evenings
okay so this is all thanks to to graph
learning that we find our way to the
place but also back okay
good so while learning on graphs
obviously graphs are everywhere and this
is kind of the obligatory slide that you
need to have if you're talking about
graphs and they they come can be like
event curves computer networks social
networks communication networks and on
and so why is this so much interest in
craft learning is because any technique
that you come up with it can be
immediately applied to you know a whole
sense of kind of the kind of data and
this is why it's like one of the most
like most popular themes in machine
Learning Community nowadays to do uh to
do craft learning color
so what's uh how is this precisely done
and so what do I mean with this graph
learning well I'm going to talk about
what I what if some people call like
embedding based graph learning what is
the idea here is as follows so this is
the the space of all possible graphs
that you can have and so graphs with
notes and vertices and edges and so on
and here we have some output space this
can be anything here I pick like just to
really recruiting space of Dimension D
and so what you're going to do is you
want to map this discrete objects the
graphs into some continuous space using
some embedding methods and why do you
want to do that very simply because of
course in this space in this nice
euclidean spaces continuous spaces this
is where most the bulk of the classical
machine learning uh methodologies and
techniques kind of work very well for
example support Vector machines or deep
neural networks they will operate on
vectors and so they cannot deal with the
graph itself you first have to get from
the graph roads to the discontinuous
space over there okay
so so what's new and so why don't we do
the following and so we take a graph we
have five cycle curve we take the
adjacency Matrix we flatten it into a
vector and we just this is our output
space it's going to be a 10 dimensional
space or you can also reduce it if
because it's if you have direct
undirected graphs you can have it and
then you can just apply a deep neural
network or a support Vector machine on
top of this so why doesn't this work or
why is this not the the way to go ahead
because of course you have different
representations of the same graph and
you can have like all possible
permutations of this Matrix that will
result in different flattened factors
and basically and they will be outfit
into the same methods so if you take a
support Vector machine for example or a
deep deep neural network that will
create different outputs depending on
the representation that is chosen and
this is of course not what you want you
don't want to get a certain prediction
depending on which way you ordered your
your vertices in the curve and so this
is a very important difference and this
is also why classical methods don't
really work well because what you would
need to do is try all possible
permutations and then somehow average
out the results just to make sure that
they're kind of oblivious to The Chosen
representation of your input structure
okay
so instead of just general embeddings so
what graph learning typically operates
with our so-called invariant embeddings
and basically what you want is that your
embeddings are going to be carving
variants and so there basically needs to
be giving the same results if you give
isomorphic inputs uh if you give
isomorphic inputs and this is of course
for those from the database Theory this
is very something which we're familiar
with but this is conflict genericity in
query languages
a bit more formal but not so formal is
like a p vertex embedding and this is
the open this is the kind of things that
map the graphs you know space g to some
mapping from vertices to the output
space we say that is invariant if for
any graph any vertex and so on and every
isomorphism they give the same result as
I'm not defining anything else and just
saying they give the same results on
isomorphic inputs and how is this
invariance achieved in graph learning is
basically by constructing methods that
do graph learning by composing Atomic
operations that are actually kind of
invariants by definition and so by
composition you will end up with an
invariance setting over there okay
so what is now graph learning and so now
we know the ingredients we go from
crafts our space of graphs to some
continuous space we're going to do these
bits by means of uh this invariant
embeddings at taking the discrete
objects mapping it to some continuous
element in some space and so now what is
the learning aspect well we know we're
giving and this is just the
semi-supervised setting we're gonna be
starting from some training sets this
training set consists of drugs potential
vertices or more than one vertices and
some output label and these are the
precise values that you want to predict
or the class to classifier the label of
the classification and so on that's R
set D and then typically what is done is
you do empirical risk minimization and
this is just one way that you could do
the learning and what is the goal here
this is simply an optimization problem
where you want to find in your space
here of all hypothesis class which
consists of invariant embeddings and so
you fix a hypothesis class consisting of
this invariant embeddings you will find
want to find unembedding or that
embedding that basically minimizes your
empirical loss which is nothing else
than given a loss function you just want
to measure for each element in your
hypothesis class which is an invariant
embedding you measure its prediction
corresponding to the given label in the
training sets and you just want to
minimize this this is just one example
of this there are many different
formalizations of this but intuitively
it's just an optimization problem which
is solved by means of back propagation
credit descent and so on so but the most
important important ingredients
ingredient in this in this stock will be
this hypothesis class H consisting of
invariant embeddings okay so that's
going to be the focus from Iran sure
example of why
to get the graph the vertex and then
here's the Y that you're trying to so
why could work for example so the
question is stack so you mean this Y is
in the training set right so for example
just think about this as a graph and it
can be for example this curve might
represent a molecule and you won't for
example say is this molecule does it
have a certain property yes or no in
that case y would be zero or one or yes
or no or you could ask like you know a
certain again for a graph does it have a
certain percentage or like a like a
value and it would be like a irrigation
problem where you get like 0.5 0.6 and
so on so these are the actual things
that you want to learn yeah think of
examples of things they want to learn
yeah so if you think back about for
example this link prediction for example
you're in a recommendation system what
you want to predict is the value between
two vertices whether they should be
connected yes or no so in that case what
you would given you would give a graph
you get two vertices V and W and then
zero or one depending on whether there
is an H between then yes or no so you're
given some partial knowledge about what
you want to learn and the hope is now
that in your hypothesis class you have
to go find an invariant embedding that
explains well the given information in
the training sets but of course
hopefully also generalizes to unseen
examples
some sort of vector
I should have explained this is like a
couple of vertices
yeah so it can be also no vertex then
it's basically just a graph as you would
have a graph label graph label and so on
if you want to predict things on the
vertex level it's a cover vertex label
curve vertex label and so on if you want
to link prediction you have a graph two
vertices and so on as well yes thanks
for the question what are your typical
loss functions that can be anything I
mean it can be just least squared I can
be uh you know like a euclidean they can
be like just some entropy based or so on
so it really depends on the application
uh depends also whether you do
regression if you want to predict a
continuous value or whether you want to
do like a classification of Boolean like
finite label classification there are so
many there are libraries full of of loss
functions and they're very important
when you actually want to learn
something but in this talk I'm just
going to you know make my life easy and
just use loss it will never appear any
more in the talk but we can maybe take
this offline afterwards okay yeah
um I think in general it's hard to say
if like to to just classify whether two
girls are isomorphic
so like it is is it necessary to enforce
this or could you also have like a
looser notion
you you could yeah so this is something
that's that's being discussed in the
community that maybe this notion of calf
isomorphism is too strict for the graph
learning setting and there should be
more like a like a more like an isomet
isometric kind of a more continuous
version of this where you embed your job
in some space and then have some kind of
more geometric notion of similarity yeah
yeah good question
Okay so
and so this is what is learning
optimization problem and um so we know
now what the graph learning is about and
so but of course the big question is
what are these hypothesis classes and so
what are examples of this invariant
embeddings that actually will do the job
because it's that's very crucial and so
each of us can have its own or her own
hypothesis class that you hope is going
to explain and really do a very good job
in explaining your training data and
generalization uh first things uh that
you didn't see before
and of course hypothesis classes have
been around for for ages and so they
think going back from the 1970s and this
was way before deep learning and so on
and they were really kind of
fingerprinting and kind of you took a
molecule and you extracted some features
number of five cycles and so on you just
took some like handcrafted feature
engineering you mapped it into some some
space and then you apply some functions
on it some classical machines
and so there's a whole kind of you know
history behind graph learning and
starting from this handcrafted
handcrafted features then kernel kernel
methods were very popular uh for a long
time but then I want to forget about all
that and actually jump to 2017 2018 and
so on since then basically there were
lots of like deep learning and graph
neural network kind of style embedding
methods that that's a hosts so this is
basically going to be the focus on the
topic of the rest of the talk okay so
here you see like neural message passing
models graph States kgnns and so on I
will explain uh more about this now what
is going on in the community is that
um every second almost on archived or
new methods being proposed okay and so
this is really amazing like it's a very
good time to to be in this area because
you can actually just continuously check
uh archive and then there's a new
methods you can start analyzing it and
you have your next paper ready you can
put it on archive so it's like you know
it's like it's like a cycle it's like
it's beautiful okay
um okay
um and so I think yeah yeah okay that's
it yeah so these are that's all the
things I had and so of course the
questions like what to do with this and
so these are kind of as you see maybe
craft former very popular you have
isomorphism network of convolutional
network message Crossing you have
attention networks work DNS you have
chip Nets scaling Nets simplicational
simplicial mpns uh random mpns I mean
it's so it's a whole zoo okay so and
each of these basically you can fit in
into this and we're gonna go back one
slide because the animation has to go
over and over again so if you think
about this optimization problem so each
of these sub for example ordered
subproof networks is one hypothesis
class that you can train and find the
best invariant embedding for it and so
that's basically the the the the
importance of these things so big
question if you're coming from like
query language or like database here and
so on so how to compare these things and
so how can we say anything about these
two different methods uh how can we
bring order to the chaos okay and that's
basically what we're going to do in uh
in the rest of the talk and so what
we're going to see is we're going to
look at this graph embeddings that I
just set us on these slides if you're
going trying to code and see this as
query language queries in some query
language okay then we are going to
analyze the expressive power of these
query languages so we're going to
actually make an abstraction we're not
going to look at specific you know
implementations of one simple like you
know embedding methods we're going to
look at that queries at query languages
study expressive power and then
hopefully transfer this understanding
back to the craft learning uh scenario
so that's basically the what that is
what is the power of learning in the
title refers to as we're going to look
at the expressive power of the query
languages and transfer these results
back to the craftronic community
okay
what's two questions what kind of
language and so what do we mean by
expressive power so that's the first the
second part will be and so we have done
the craft learning Parts I hope that
everybody knows now what it is about and
what we're kind of trying to achieve it
just remember this volcano this you know
erupting number of kind of methods we're
going to try to analyze them in some
other way by means of a graph embedding
language
so if you look at all these papers that
present and introduce models so
typically they are specified in terms of
very it's not simple like linear algebra
computations interleaved with some
non-linear active function nonlinear
function applications
a crucial component in many of these
methods that are in the literature is a
multiplication with the adjacency Matrix
which basically corresponds to our
neighborhood application so if we want
to have any chance at all of
representing very goods or kind of very
popular half learning methods embedding
methods in terms of a query language we
need definitely function application and
some aggregation and so that's basically
already two takeaways that we you know
so let us first see a concrete example
of an embedding class so embedding class
H just to get a bit more intuition what
I mean by this functional application
and application and these are the
so-called graph neural networks 101s so
what we're going to do is we're just
having nonlinear activation functions
that are typically in deep Learning
Systems the value sine Sigma and so on
we're going to represent the embedding
for vertices by means of a matrix and so
here we have n vertices and let's say we
fix the dimension and which in which
we're going to embed the vertices to D
so every of these matrices will
basically look like this and this will
just saying this is the feature or the
embedding for vertex V1 this is for v2
and V3 and then we have weight matrices
in every layer and so it's deep learning
I forgot to say this so we have a number
of layers so for this is parameterized
by D and for every layer we have like
weights two weight matrices and we have
some bias Factor okay and then basically
how do we kick start this process we
start at layer 0 by means of an initial
hot one encoding of the labels of the
graph and so this is basically just the
standard way you kick off the process
Kickstarter process by some initial
labeling and then you inductively define
what is my new embedding as their T I'm
defining this in the is those that I got
from layer T minus one and so what I do
I take a weighted combination from the
previous layer features and then here
crucially I'm taking the aggregation
over the neighbors using multiplication
with edges The Matrix of the features
again computed from the previous layer
and I'm adding some bias okay and this
is and then of course you apply a
nonlinear activation function and that's
one layer in a graph neural network and
it is then repeated until a certain
amount of layers and then finally this
is basically Computing and embedding for
vertices and so the every this is a
matrix every vertex is an embedding and
so of course what you you can do is
collapse all this by summing up all the
obtained embeddings of all the vertices
in your graph again weighted with some
weight Matrix as some bias apply an
activation function and then basically
what you get is a representation an
embedding of the entire curve and so we
have seen two things here we have seen
two operations that are crucial okay
actually we have here neighborhood
aggregation that I mentioned before the
application of a function and also there
are many functions applied here we have
also product of real numbers and so on
so lots of function applications are
going on and then we have also
aggregation over all the vertices
so what is now the hypothesis class for
this particular GNN formalism they're
basically just all these functions that
map G to this Vector FG and this is
parameterized by all the weights that we
have seen at the W1 the W2 in every
layer the biases and so on and then if
you think back about this optimization
problem it is expected empirical risk
minimization so what is the goal here of
learning by means of this Gene and 101s
it's just trying to figure out what are
the best possible parameters what are
the best possible weight matrices that
if I plug them into my formalism I get I
minimize this loss that I want and so
that's basically how this goes back to
okay
good so based on this it's now very easy
to build a curve embedding language and
so what we're going to do is just
defining a gel expression and gel stands
for carbon embedding language which if
we will have a syntax and so we have a
5x we associate a dimension to it we
also associate three variables to these
expressions and then the semantics of
such Expressions will just be these
embeddings and so where you see that
we're going to map graphs add to some
function from vertices to some output
space and here this L the dimension how
many vertices we'll need are determined
by the number of three variables if we
have zero variables I'm talking about
graphs and so then we have to be just
mapping graph to an outputs if I have
one free variable I'm doing a Vertex
embedding two three variables I will
have an edge embedding and so on and
then the D is basically the dimension
associated with the expression and so
the little typing system going on
and actually what we're just going to do
is just defining a very simple version
of query languages that some of us might
have seen before so query languages with
either H Aggregates have been studied by
for by Leonard Lipkin and and others in
it around two thousands and actually I
learned about data logo it's actually
also a little bit similar in spirit to
data logo in some sense but it's more
specialized to real numbers and there
are more aggregations and functional
applications
second so how do you build such a gel
expression typically you start from
Atomic expressions and these are just
like we have labels as you can have
formulas representing a label they will
have Dimension one one single free
variable and for example label j x i if
you evaluate this expression over a
graph and you get an assignment of the x
i variable to a Vertex then basically
what you're going to return is the Jade
feature of of the vertex V
if I do the H here we have a backer gel
expression Phi x i x j if it's equal to
e x i x j basically given a graph given
an assignment of the variables x y and
XJ into V vertex V and vertex W it's
just going up to one if it's an edge to
zero otherwise and of course and we also
have equality basically we have like you
know an indicator function of two
variables x y and XJ
given in graph J again assignment of the
variables x i and x j to the two
vertices it's going to be mapping to one
if these vertices are the same and to
zero otherwise okay these are the atomic
ways that we can kick start the
construction of this gel expressions and
now we just need to close this on the
function application and so what does
this mean we start with a bunch of gel
Expressions V1 or to VL each of them
come with their own Dimension let's say
D1 d2dl three variables X1 to XL
now we take a function this can be any
function that you can think of going
from the hills to the hills where we
have here the empty Dimension is the sum
of the dimension of the inputs and the
output Dimension is the D okay and now
we can make a new expression 5x where we
just apply this function f to the com to
the Expressions that we had before and
this will be now of Dimension D and the
three variables will be the one the
unions of all the three variables that
were before
so what does this corresponds
semantically this is just going to be
embedding that given a graph given an
assignment of the variables to vertices
it's just going to be the application of
this function and from the reals to the
reels here
um on what on the outputs of the
individual previously defined shell
expressions of the by filling in again
the same grab of course and restricting
the valuations to the variables that are
appearing in the individual components
of the thing
so and this is it for the F you can take
any linear algebraic computation you can
take activation function anything you
want okay this is basically just
um you know symbolically just like a
function application aggregation we also
need and so what is this so here we're
having two expressions Phi 1 and Phi 2
there are zero expressions of Dimension
D1 and D2 three variables X and Y and
now what we're going to do is we're
going to take note of function from the
hills to the hills but we're going to
take a function Theta which Maps box of
factors in R to the power D1 and so d
one dimensional vectors are back Optima
multi-set to some Vector in RT and we're
just going to apply this is now a new
formula that we can make we can actually
get using this function and from the
backs of vectors to a vector given this
uh for this possible variables Y and
here we have the two component
Expressions Phi 1 and Phi 2. okay this
will be an expression of Dimension d d
is the dimension of this function Theta
and variables X which are the ones that
are not projected out okay what is the
semantics this is the semantics we're
taking a graph we're taking a valuation
of the variables X yeah so the not y but
the X and then we are going to construct
a multi-set and what is this multi-set
consist of we're just going to collect
all the embeddings obtained by the graph
by assigning uh two x and to Y factors
and then we're using the Phi 2 as a
guard and so we're only taking in the
multi-sets all the vectors that we can
can obtain as long as this second
condition is satisfied meaning that you
get a non-zero answer and this is kind
of a conditional aggregation if you wish
so let me give you an example here
and this is an aggregation example so
where we're taking the sum as our
summation we have V3 variables X Y uh
sets this is what is the Phi one it's
just a trivial indicator function it's
always going to map to one and so the
every evaluation will map this to one
and then here we have a condition and we
multiply the H the e x y times e y sets
y e times x times x and then some
indicator functions and here I'm using
the dot as a shorthand for product
function application and this is also a
shorthand for one minus uh something and
so this is a shorthand notation so what
does this compute just to to fill the
room
okay and so I just got the confirmation
so we got the Guinness World Records for
the assignments program in which the
triangle query is featured the most okay
so this is like very we should celebrate
afterwards this is uh amazing okay
so let's see a more elaborate example so
here we have message passing networks
these are generalizations of graphene of
the GNN 101s they are basically we're
going to replace this linear algebra
matrix multiplication with arbitrary
aggregation but importantly we're only
allowing aggregation where the where the
guards is basically the edge so we're
only allowing to Aggregates over uh over
vertices that are in the neighborhood of
other vertices and that's basically what
this condition here means and so here
we're taking we again at level zero we
have some initial labeling let's say
just constant one and then for every
layer we Define a gel expression a lot
like an expression in our language for
layer T it's going to be some function
application an update function apply to
two components the thing that I got from
the previous layer this is again
expression combined with the aggregation
for some aggregation function for my
variable X2 applied on the expression
that I got from the previous layer
conditioned on the edge and so I only
going to kind of just look at if you do
look at the semantics given a curve
given a Vertex mapping for it for for X1
we're just gonna look at all the
neighbors of this V1
looking at the previously computed
features aggregating in them in some way
and then up buying an extra update
if we do a readout layer we want to
collapse this into a graph
representation then what we can do is we
take for example our expression after
layer l that's of course we have L
layers okay this is my expression and
now we just do like a dummy guards and
so we do like unconditional aggregation
so basically this is always going to be
one so we're just going to aggregate
over everything which basically means
that we're looking at all the vertices
and we're going to collapse the
Expressions all the features that we
compute into one single expression again
using some aggregation brush
and this encompasses the Gene and 101s
and as you can see it's a very simple
translation of uh you know
of like things that that you see in the
papers and machine graph learning that
you can almost like trivially kind of
encode this into this gel expression by
means of the right aggregation functions
okay
importantly and so we're coming I'm
coming also from the database Theory so
we like fragments of query languages and
so what we're going to do is we're
looking at two fragments of this
language namely gel K
Omega Theta and so this is the K
variable fragment of gel and so I can
only use K variables so I have X1 X2 op
x k and we can take functions in some
set Omega and some aggregation functions
from that Theta and we also look at the
guarded fragments of this gel expression
of this gel language which is a two is a
fragment of the two variable fragment of
gel whereby only allowing aggregations
where this card is going to be this H
and so this was on the previous slides
so this ionic are allowed in this
component here I only can do the the the
edge application and this will be the
condition I can only range over the
neighborhoods and this is the guarded
gel two Omega data fragments okay so it
will become immediately clear why I'm
doing that so first observation this MP
and ends that I just explained on the
previous slides that fit perfectly in
this guarded gel with uh with some omega
and some datas which are enough to kind
of support aggregation functions and the
functions
without readout phase and the readout
phase is the face where I'm collapsed
collapse collecting all the vertex
information into one single information
for for the graph this is something you
cannot do in the garden fragments why
not because this requires you to do
aggregation Beyond neighborhoods I need
to aggregate over all possible vertices
but of course if I do this if I include
the late the last round last phase of my
mpns then I fit into gel to Omega data
this talk become clear what is important
remember this mpns message passing
neural networks are one of the most
popular Frameworks that exist and so
it's very important that these two
things fit into these fragments of gray
languages and in fact
so this is like a reduced version of
this uh volcano most of the hypothesis
classes that we encountered in the
literature actually fits in summer of
the way uh sometimes very easy sometimes
it requires a little bit more work to
actually kind of squeeze this into this
gel K language and so here we see for
example in Reds we have like like all
Gardens uh versions these are kind of
mpns of course I just saw also the Gins
and the gcns they're all can be fit into
this guarded gel fragments Expressions
then the blue ones are ones that
actually fits into the gel too so that
needs not only the guarded uh
aggregation but also unguarded still
with two variables the green ones need
three variables and so on and so on and
so why is this important because this
puts order to the chaos and because now
what you need to do or what you can do
if you come up with a new graph
embedding methods you can try to squeeze
it into this gel language and try to
minimize the number of variables that
you need and automatically you know some
you know to which family that you belong
do you need one variable two variable
one variable facility but two variables
three variables and so on so this gives
you information about what is the
complexity in some sense of your graph
neural network of your of your new
methods okay
so this is the the first part and so
when I'm asking what is the query
language that we should look at this is
like this graph this this uh this
embedding language and this is like a
suggestion of course here and we need
still to answer what I mean by
expressive power yeah I'm pretty new to
Keynotes that's why I play the hunt with
this with this feature here okay
so expressive power and so everything
clears so far so what the only thing
that we did was I explained a little bit
about craft learning then I showed you
this this zoo of methods I told you that
we were going to try to look at them
from more database perspective database
serious language perspective and
actually try to put some order in all
these different methods and one way that
we achieve this by actually trying to to
find to define a language and then
parameterizes by number of variables
being guarded not being guarded and then
actually trying to squeeze these methods
in the right fragments and now the next
part will of course be to to see what
can we learn from this and so what what
information does this give us about
graph learning methods
the 25 levels
is it because your gods are binary what
happens if you have three value of the
fragments but
that's a new paper that's a new method
in graph learning let's work on this
next week
actually that's a good question
of course if you have three variables
there are different ways that you you
are we that you could guard it like if
you have let's discuss it offline yeah
the two is basically just because this
corresponds to the message passing your
networks and I'll show you later why
this comes up okay
so expressive power already all the
questions
so one of the most important or most
studied Notions of expressive power in
the graph Learning Community is what is
called the distinguishing power or
separating power or it comes in many uh
names and this basically just asks which
inputs can be separated or distinguished
by embeddings in your hypothesis class
think about this hypothesis classes and
this message passing neural networks the
mpns and so this question just asked
like given to graphs for example can you
find can you embed them differently in
your output space and that's basically
is this possible yes or no of course if
you can answer this question then you
gain information about what is the power
of message passing neural networks for
example because suppose you cannot
distinguish two graphs they're always
embedded in the same way then suppose
you want to learn a function that
actually trades these two input graphs
differently then there's no way that the
message passing neural networks will be
will be helpful because you just showed
that these graphs will always get
embedded in the same way and so this is
the The crucial uh aspect of the
importance of this of this relation
and this is captured by an equivalence
relation consisting of graphs and
purpose of vertices graphs in terms of
vertices which are basically in this
equivalent escalation a row of
hypothesis class of H if for all
embeddings in your hypothesis class this
embedding gives the same result so
basically it means these two elements
here are indistinguishable with respect
to the embeddings in the embedding
methods in your hypothesis class this is
something that is you know this is like
logical indistinguishability and so the
offer with the query language is given
to databases or can can they be
distinguished by some logical sentence
this is precisely this but translated to
the uh to the the graph learning or the
embedding side of things
just said to make clear that you
understand this concept and so strongest
power means that this hypothesis class
is going to be strong enough to detect
um non-isomorphic halves so if you have
maximal the maximal power that you can
give a hypothesis method other animating
class or hypothesis class is when this
row of H this equivalence relation
precisely only contains the
non-isomorphic half the isomorphic half
sorry so this means that if two graphs
are non-isomorphic you will can embed
them differently that's the maximum
power that you can give a hypothesis
class the weakest power of course is
when all graphs are mapped to the same
elements let's say the zero Vector then
this basically this row of H consists of
all pairs of graphs and that's really
like a graph and hypothesis Clause that
you don't want to work with and so
that's and everything in between is of
course what is going to happen in
practice okay just to make sure and so
if you have two methods methods one
methods two and this relation hold this
means that methods one is more powerful
than method two and all method two is
bounded in power by Method one and of
course if there are equal disease
relations these equivalence relations
then these methods are in principle uh
equally powerful okay
well the nice thing about this
definition is that actually here you can
replace this by anything you can take an
algorithm you can take a large kind of
logic you can still always just look at
the equivalence relation given some
methods can you distinguish this input
yes or not so this relationship this
this equivalence condition allows you to
not only compare different classes of
embeddings let's say message passing
neural networks and you have attention
networks and so on but also you can
compare with algorithms that work on
graphs or with logic that we can't hear
of they're just Galatians on equivalence
relations on graphs and then vertices so
you can kind of really start mixing in
uh and comparing different emotions with
each other
and so in the machine Learning Community
the most focused so far has been on
trying to characterize for this volcano
of methods what is the distinguishing
power of these things
so what we're going to do in this talk
is just obtaining some logic based uh
characterization and um and so what we
will basically need is psychologic and
so the reason that they looked at this
gave variable fragment of the gel
language and the guarded fragment of
this gel language is of course because I
knew what what I want what we wanted to
show is that basically this can be
characterized or is very closing in
close correspondence to to other logical
like logical fragments that are more
studied and well studied in
for example in this what is most
important is versatile logic with K
variables and with counting quantifiers
so that's going to be playing a crucial
role in the analysis for example for k
equal 2 you're allowed to use two
variables and then of course you have an
edge predicate and some unary label
predicates and then on top of that you
have counting quantifiers that can ask
those that exist that exist less than
five wise such that something holds or
do that exist more than two x's such as
something else and these are kind of
simple logic that is kind of fixed in
the number of variables that you can use
of course notes I can reuse variables
that's of course crucial otherwise
there's not so much you can do and of
course if you also have counting which
is kind of
so what does this formula tells you this
is going to be satisfied given a graph
and a vertice vertex if this vertex has
five at most five neighbors and each of
each of which which at least two
neighbors labeled a and that's basic at
least if that's what I hold there it
should be correct that's the semantics
of this logical expression and we also
have a guarded fragment of this logic
where basically the existential
pontification is always guarded in this
form we're always going to guard it
guard it into a conjunction with the H
relation similarly as how we defined
this uh this guarded fragment for the
gel embedding language okay
and so what is now the expressive power
of gel that I was mentioning before well
you can see here that following really
standard analysis things that we know as
database theoreticians that you can
actually throw most of the almost like
all the real real number computation and
so on it doesn't really matter right so
you can you can actually collapse the
entire from a point of view of
distinguishability whether you can map
two graphs to different items and so on
it's everything is actually captured by
Logic and not nothing has to do not not
there's nothing to do with real numbers
and so on so what this tells you is that
for the guarded fragment of gel
that this equivalence relation is the
same as the one that you obtained by the
guarded fragment of this two variable
first of the logic fragments bit
counting quantifiers and more General if
you have the gay version you're allowed
to do K variables then this corresponds
to the K variable fragments of this of
this logic and so what does this tells
is that you can once you start if you
think back about this pyramids you take
your graph learning methods you squeeze
it into gel K and you write it just a
logical formulas in the thing here what
we you find out is that the
distinguishing power of your
um of your graph learning methods is
completely Bound By The Power of this
logic and of course this is very
important because these things have been
studied for a long time and people know
lots of tools to actually try to figure
out which graphs can be distinguished by
such logical formulas yes or no
um the one cycle Mark is the low so the
upper bounds so it's always upper
bounded by this uh by these Logics for
any Omega and Omega data and these are
the functions and the functions and the
aggregations for the lower bonds you
need to have some conditions namely that
you that your Omega your functions you
need to do linear combinations
concatenation and taking up products or
you don't need products but then you
have aluminum nonlinear activation
function and it's sufficient for the
aggregation function to be summation
that's really the only thing that you
need to actually make this this equality
of equality holds okay
so this is the connection and so this is
the the third step in some sense so now
you take
your machine learning curve machine
learner you make your methods what do
you do you try to cast it in the right
shell k
how many variables do I actually need to
to make things work
and then you know
from the previous results that you're
going to be bounded in power
distinguishing Power by the K variable
fragment of this first of logic with K
variables and so you immediately know
quite a lot
you need to do a little bit more to get
the the other side and so if your method
is actually powerful enough to encode
its formulas and so somehow to capture
the semantics of this of this logic as
well then you have the auto inclusions
as well okay so you get automatic upper
bounds once you found the right GLK to
fit in to where your method fits in for
the lower bounds you still have to do
some work and it's really kind of a one
one by one case analysis and so this can
be done and so this has been done in a
recent paper we look at all these
methods and then try to see you know
which ones are kind of you know
also kind of uh like powerful enough to
actually capture the semantics of The
Logical performance and this really
gives you the precise information about
the distinguishing power of this graph
learning methods by The Detour of the
query language because that's easier to
formulate it in than throwing away
everything and going to logic and that's
uh that's it and that's that kind of
story
just to make sure that you understand it
so we have GNN 101s
um it was shown in a very nice paper
from 2019 that is Geno 1101 is actually
corresponds to these two variable uh
fragment of first order logic with
counting and so this is also a
consequence of the of the gel things
that I mentioned before
um so this means that they're pretty
weak and so for those who know this
logic there are lots of graphs that are
actually you know that you would like to
distinguish but are not distinguishable
in this logic and so here this is like a
like a quintessential example we have
two triangles and again triangle query
triangles coming up and we have a six
cycle question is can we train a GNN a
gene and 101 can we find parameters
using this empirical risk minimization
whatever method that you want so that
you embed this graph differently from
that one and the answer is no and why is
this because of course this curves G and
H they're known to be indistinguishable
by this logic and using some several
game arguments I'm sure Focus can
explain how this can be done uh of site
and so what does this mean that g h are
actually in this same relation in this
in the equivalence relation for the
logic and since this is the same as the
GNN 101 you know that there is no GNN on
Earth that can separate these two things
okay
is this clear okay so now because this
is a this is the Garf lecture we have to
solve P equal and P okay so this is one
of the my goals today is really to kind
of just make this uh you know end this
whole debate whether it's equal or not
so again remember we have here two pfp
and NP question is can we train a GNN
that makes p different from NP or are we
are they always going to be the same
so who thinks they're equal
things are different
and why are they different because the
cycle length
okay there's easier angst answer
one is disconnected
that's not not not uh that's true
so I'll just that's all easiest thing
that
so this B has only one single note of
degree one well this one has one and two
and so you can make a sentence in logic
in C2 saying there exist precisely one
okay this is a short time notation
precisely One X so that we explicitly
one y that that is in the H relation
with X which meaning that is not this is
a single to K1 nodes okay and obviously
B satisfies it at least precisely one
and here we have one two and three so
this is a sentence that is not satisfied
by NP meaning that b and NP are
different from each other and they're in
this they're not in this relationship
they're not in this equivalence relation
which means because you also have the
hardness the G and 101 these are as
powerful as the logic this means that
you can find parameters the the weights
and the biases you can instantiate this
you know with the number of layers so
that in the end you're going to embed p
and NP differently okay and I think this
is really the end of this whole p and
and P business and uh yeah I think I
should stop here
yes I already have them yeah so
um so
maybe I should stop here but I still
have some time left so let me continue
uh this is like one side of the story so
there are very beautiful connections
between like other ways of
characterizing this this uh this
equivalence relation so I I mentioned
this with the logic but there are this
very nice results that for example for
the C2 you can actually kind of tell
whether two curves are in this
equivalence relation even only if the
homomorphism counts for any tree in the
graph G and the graph H are equal to
each other and so what this means is
they just take G and H you take any tree
for if our all trees the homomorphism
count and these two graphs are the same
then this is equal then there are going
to be indistinguishable by this by this
logic and traversely and this
generalizes to the higher versions to
the P plus one variable setting where
then you have to replace the trees with
three with b and this is I think a very
beautiful connection and why is this
important and why is this nice is
because for example for the message
passing neural networks they're like
very common very popular curve learning
methods we in order related to the C2
we know that they're basically only
looking at and this result basically
tells you that this message passed in
neural networks can only detect tree
based information there's nothing else
that is actually inspected by this
message passing neural networks if you
look at methods that use more variables
let's say three variables then again you
know that you're only going to look at
three which uh two patterns like a three
click and so on but not more you cannot
distinguish graphs with a forklick and
not a four click and so on so
immediately you get very nice intuitive
information about these classes of
methods
um I'm gonna skip because I'm running a
bit out of time
there are lots of different Notions that
you can look at you can also ask you
know which uh which things can be
approximated by hypothesis class this is
about distinguishing given to inputs can
you embed them differently
you have approximation results where
basically also the is distinguishing in
a nutshell but you can show under
certain conditions is that classes
hypothesis classes that are closed on
the linear combinations and products
that they can
approximate any continuous function as
long as this function has not more
distinguishing power than the one of
your hypothesis class
for example here if you look at these
two graphs again
they're in this equivalence collation
and this means that you cannot
approximate any functional dip that
depends on connected components because
they have different components or three
clicks and so on and this is a very nice
nice connection between this
distinguishing power and approximation
properties you can also look at VC
Dimension and again I'm going to skip it
but in the recent paper we connected
this distinguishing power relation to
the VC dimension of these embedding
methods and you can also ask like really
in a logical sense which queries which
computations can actually be expressed
by embeddings in an hypothesis class
this is like really two expressiveness
as we know it in Greg languages and this
is what a very nice paper by by Pablo
Barcelona and and Miguel Monet who is
not here I think at the moment where
they basically show that
um let me show you the results they
showed that if you assume that your
formula that or the query that you're
looking for is a C2 formula uh then this
is going to be equivalent then this can
be expressed by a message passing neural
network even only the formula is
actually in this guarded fragment and so
they kind of really connect this and
this is like uniform expressiveness
meaning that this is going to be an MPN
and that really is going to give you the
answer for all possible inputs
and then this was recently uh expanded
considerably by by marketing grower that
actually actually bounded and precisely
found its connection to not the the C2
logic but the two variable first two
variable fragment of first order logic
with counting quantifiers but this is a
completely different animal this is like
a two-sorted logic where you have
numerical comparisons and so on
okay so this is somehow the story that I
wanted to tell I have some conclusions I
don't know whether I have time for the
conclusions
after two minutes or yeah
um mpns they are the most efficient and
most widely used but they're very weak
expressive power and actually in the two
seminal papers by Chester from Morris
and Martin grower and so on and also
true and Helga and leskovic where they
made the first connection with this
expressiveness uh with this expressive
power the fact that this empties are so
weak has led to a flurry of new matters
trying to boost the expressive power of
craft learning methods so it's maybe not
so on itself the most interesting thing
to actually find out what is the
aggressive power but you now have like a
really like a yardstick that you can
compare with and so this and the whole
area is really trying to to show I'm
coming up with the new methods and then
showing oh look we can do more than a
previous method and this more has now
really formally defined in terms of this
logic unfortunately for K larger than 2
you need not matrices but you need
tensors things are gonna is like
completely inefficient and uh what
people do instead of that is they try to
do feature augmentation where they
pre-compute some information like
compounds or isomorphism counts things
which you cannot capture by the mpns and
feed it into the beginning into the
pipeline there are no features
surprisingly if you have random features
you suddenly become Universal and so
this is some real nice results and then
spectralink Global properties where you
take spectral components and so on and
here the logic really fails and so there
is no clear understanding of what is
this logic X how you can interpret it
like eigenvalues and eigenvectors uh
enriched graph learning methods and so
on so lots of things to do there in
terms of expressive power and then very
very popular at the moment are so-called
subgraph gnns and so what are these
instead of looking at one single graph a
given Javas inputs you you're basically
going to make a bunch of crafts by for
example deleting all possible edges one
by one it's all vertices like you can if
you have a graph of size n you're going
to have n copies of the graph each of
them with one vertex removed and then
you're running on each of these copies
in parallel a graph neural network you
embed them and you Aggregate and these
are the subscription ends again
completely open like you know expensive
power there are some results there but
many things left okay
more to those and so
um so the analysis analysis that I
presented does not always show up in the
experiments and so there are many
embedding methods that are in the same
class same expressive power same
properties but one really outperforms
the other why nobody knows and so the
tools that I presented are still lacking
and there is room for improvement there
to look maybe also at a training how the
training actually happens and so there
was a question earlier like what is this
loss function I completely ignored this
here but maybe this is something that I
shouldn't that we shouldn't do maybe we
should take this into account and see
how we created this sentence or
interleaves with this expressive power I
also didn't mention graph phones which
are also very popular and these are
limits of graphs and all these things I
don't know any work that connects this
with explosivity uh in the standard I
mentioned before
is using this connection with shell more
transferable of knowledge possible from
the database Community to the craft
Learning Community or vice versa I hope
so
um and I'm gonna recurrent gnns are
closely related to fixed Point
computation recurrency and then is one
that repeats the same layer over and
over and over and again again there what
is what is this story with logic with uh
with expressive power and so on and of
course also relational embeddings
uh so conclusion at queer language Lord
and logic point of view provides in my
opinion very good abstraction of what is
going on in the area of Health learning
using classical results and not so
classical but in expressive power and
Analysis of these query languages we
easily get results and understanding
about what graph learning methods can do
and I think this is a very great
opportunity and there's lots of still
low hanging fruits of course the longer
we wait the the higher the food hangs
but you know there's still enough low
hanging foot to actually kind of make
some impact there and so you can really
take your own thing that you love try to
see how it squeezed into this whole
graph learning business
and with that I would like to conclude
and as you can see it's still ongoing
right yeah so there we go yeah thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so have you considered uh this
distinguishing power within classes of
graphs so maybe uh with with
English between two trees or only planar
graphs instead of you know distinguish
distinguishing all uh all possible
graphs
you mean uh so the so you mean like to
to restrict for example look at trees
but for trees it's easy because trees
can be already distinguished by by the
C2 by message plus in your network right
yeah so that's good enough for trees
right so that's good enough for trees
for larger classes no I don't know any
work on on that but it's a very
interesting question whether you can
actually count off if you know
um if you know that your data satisfies
certain property maybe certain methods
are kind of more powerful but this is I
didn't look at it maybe there are some
results in other areas that can be
applied there but it's an interesting
question yeah
hmm
is there any way to connect it to the
quality of the predictions in the end
because let's say you neural networks
right the Deep network is not really
more expressive than a shallow network
but somehow they learn much better
and maybe it's just a method the
learning method is not good enough for
the shallow networks but is there
something here where you can maybe
there's any hope to show certain kind of
embeddings allow you to get better
predictions
that I I wish I wish this was the case
so actually theoretically again the more
layers you add the more quantifier depth
you get in your formulas and your child
expressions in theory the more powerful
you become in practice this doesn't
happen at all like you get over
smoothing and all this kind of things
that's going on and again this is really
where the theory falls falls short I
mean there is of course theory kind of
not logic based but really kind of you
know convergence based and lipstick
conditions and how everything all the
the real analysis right so the
continuous aspects and of the learning
that people show convergence in a
certain condition to an optimal lens and
the convergence rate but this is a
completely different way of looking at a
problem
and so I wish this was there but it's
not there yet
so it's possible the simpler embedding
may actually give you better predictions
absolutely absolutely you can you can
train like a very complex model and not
getting much out of this and you can
take one layer or two layers
simple graph convolutional Network
and you I mean for your particular data
sets uh it's it's it it is wonders
and of course I mean in practice you
have the data the data as well I may
completely ignore the data right so you
have real data sets which behave may
they have maybe like difference uh you
know different properties that you that
is not captured by your complicated
model I don't know so that's yeah but
thank you
thank you flurries support someone
tomorrow proves that graph isomorphism
is in polynomial time and does it with a
canonization algorithm what's the
implication for this area
so now you have any variant that you can
compute in polynomial time
it's related to Remy's question because
we have many classes of graphs they say
bounded degree for where we have
polynomial time algorithms foreign
of course the thing is that you don't I
mean all the results here about
distinguish it's like it's like exact
right so actually you you always so
although you have a logical counterparts
and it's like a real isomorphism and so
on in the end what you want to do is
actually not being exact suppose you
have a precise curve isomorphism test
thing that runs in polynomial time or
you can check very efficient that two
things are going to be the same using
Color environment or like Wi-Fi element
kind of Architects so the question that
why not just run those classical
algorithms then that's not what you want
to do you want to learn right so you
want to actually not be deterministic
you don't want to be precise you want to
leave things to the open so that in your
continuous space certain information is
maybe lost
that is better for your particular data
set and function that you want to learn
otherwise you don't need learning maybe
that's what you the case that you want
to make but you know like otherwise you
can just take any deterministic
algorithm if you runs very fast you can
just run a toning curves and do it with
that but you actually want to have this
freedom of not having
precise answers or all the information
encoded for example although for example
message processing neural networks are
related to this C2 logic I mean you will
never learn such a message pass on your
network that encodes this logic in real
life because the parameters have to be
fine-tuned in such a way that is never
going to be learned so I don't know
whether this is so I don't think this
has will have an impact maybe it doesn't
impact back theoretically but in
practice you won't you want you don't
not gonna test you don't stop doing this
no no never
okay
all right so uh I want to follow up on
your
extending these two databases uh open
question so let's say we want to do
hypograph learning
do any of the results still hold or is
it trivially hold with an incident
structure and we transfer it back to
normal graph no hyper anymore I knew you
were going to ask this question but I
don't know actually
so I don't I mean there are hypercraft
of course there are hypercraft neural
net graph neural networks
um where they do some message passing
and some other way but this is not
analyzed at all and they're not very
common
um um there is a theoretically there's a
heart using incident structures or some
other kind of an encoding in curves but
not not natively high pressure it's an
interesting question it is of course
something that needs to be solved if you
want to do relational embeddings
um
that's so yeah but the answer is like it
exists but it's not it's not worked out
in detail yet
yeah
yeah okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]